This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Brian Merchant is a tech reporter, and he'd been covering the industry for years when he started to notice this term that kept coming up, especially when we would report something critical about technology we would get charges of being bloodites. Like most people, Brian knew, at least vaguely what this term, bloodite meant. If we know them at all, we usually know them by this derogatory light. We usually understand the ledites to be technophobes or people who hate technology, or it
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。布赖恩·莫昌特（Brian Merchant）是一位科技记者，当他注意到这个不断出现的词汇时，他已经报道这个行业多年了，特别是当我们报道一些对科技持批评态度的内容时，我们会遭到被称为卢德分子的指控。像大多数人一样，布赖恩对“卢德分子”这个词至少有一个模糊的概念。如果我们对他们有所了解，通常也是通过这种贬义的视角。我们通常认为卢德分子是技术恐惧者，或者是痛恨技术的人，或者它
always been this kind of term that had just sort of lodged itself into the general consciousness. But as time went on, and as Brian watched tech grow into the disruptive behemoth it is today, he started to get more curious about the actual Luddites. Who were these people whose name gets thrown around so often today in our conversations about new technology? And what did they actually believe?
一直是一种深深植根于大众意识中的词汇。但随着时间的推移，随着布赖恩看着科技发展成为今天这个颠覆性的庞然大物，他开始对真正的卢德分子产生更多的好奇。在今天我们关于新技术的讨论中，这个名字经常被到处提及，这些人到底是谁？他们实际上信仰什么？
One day I just sort of decided to dig into the term and very quickly I stumbled upon an academic paper about how they weren't doles or just confused mouth contents. They were a powerful organization with some very, very good points about why they were upset about technology and they had a very good case to make against how technology was exploiting them. The story is so much more complex, so much more nuanced, and if anything we should be sympathetic to the Luddites, especially given all the lessons that we can learn about them and how they sort of illuminate a lot of the crises still ongoing today.
有一天，我决定深入研究这个词，并且很快我偶然发现了一篇学术论文，内容关于他们并不是傻瓜或是单纯困惑的乌合之众。他们是一个拥有非常、非常有力的观点的强大组织，他们解释了为什么他们对技术感到不满，并且他们针对技术如何剥削他们提出了非常充分的理由。这个故事要复杂得多，细腻得多，如果说有什么不同的话，那就是我们应该对卢德分子抱有同情，鉴于我们可以从他们身上学到所有的教训，以及他们如何在某种程度上照亮了今天仍在持续的许多危机。
Brian has a new book out about the Luddites with a very metal title, it's called Blood in the Machine, and it explores how English textile workers in the 19th century rose up against the growing trend of automation and the machines that were threatening their livelihoods. The history feels honestly a little too relevant today, and so we wanted to have Brian on the show to tell us what we can learn from the original original Luddines. So let's set the scene. In your book, you say that the textile industry was sort of the first to be automated. So could you describe like what was textile work
布赖恩出版了一本关于卢德分子的新书，书名很有金属感，叫做《机器里的血》（Blood in the Machine），它探讨了 19th 世纪的英国纺织工人如何奋起反抗日益增长的自动化趋势以及威胁他们生计的机器。坦率地说，这段历史在今天显得有点过于切合实际了，所以我们想请布赖恩来到节目中，告诉我们能从最初的真正的卢德分子那里学到什么。让我们来设定一下背景。在你的书中，你提到纺织业可以说是最早实现自动化的行业。那么你能描述一下，在自动化机器出现之前，纺织工作是怎样的吗？
like before automated machines? So it varied a lot, but textile work was often sort of, well, today we would kind of understand to be good sort of middle class work. A lot of times the cloth workers would work at home. They were some of the first work from home proponents in that sense. They would usually work about 30 hours a week.
情况千差万别，但纺织工作通常是那种——嗯，今天我们可能会理解为相当不错的、中产阶级的工作。很多时候，织工们都在家里工作。从某种意义上说，他们是最早的居家办公倡导者。他们通常每周工作大约 30 个小时。
They could take breaks when they wanted. They could walk in their gardens. A lot of them had little farms to provide a little extra subsistence or a little extra value. The children would help spin the yarn. It was a family affair. They would sing. It was hard work. It wasn't always totally great. They would haggle with the merchants who would come to buy the cloth, but they could work on their own terms. And they really built these communities. It was this way for 200 years. And it had really sort of brought together a bunch of traditions and norms and standards that until sort of the late 1700s, when you started to see some new trends begin to impinge on that,
他们可以在想休息时休息。他们可以在花园里散步。他们中的许多人都有小农场来提供一点额外的生计或一点额外的价值。孩子们会帮忙纺纱。这是一件全家人一起参与的事。他们会唱歌。这是辛苦的工作。它并不总是完全美好的。他们会与前来买布的商人讨价还价，但他们可以按自己的意愿工作。他们确实建立起了这些社区。这种情况持续了 200 年。它确实汇集了一系列传统、规范和标准，直到 1700 年代后期，当你开始看到一些新的趋势开始侵蚀这些传统、规范和标准之前，
that they had a very well-established, sort of, nice lifestyle. And those trends that you're talking about, they involved the introduction of a bunch of new machines that automated the weaving work that humans have been doing for hundreds of years. And perhaps the most significant of those machines was the power loom. Could you tell us about it? Yeah, it's a device that automates the process of weaving itself. Something that a lot of people thought was impossible for a long time because weaving was such skilled work, but the power loom once connected to a power source like water or steam,
他们有着非常成熟、相当美好的生活方式。你所说的那些趋势，涉及引入了一系列新机器，这些机器使人类已经做了数百年的织布工作实现了自动化。而这些机器中最显著的也许就是权力织机（power loom）。你能给我们介绍一下它吗？是的，它是一种能使织布过程本身自动化的设备。很长一段时间里，许多人认为这是不可能的，因为织布是如此需要技术的熟练工作，但权力织机一旦连接到水力或蒸汽等动力源，
it could automate the process of weaving and just producing the goods in the first place. And that is a big deal. There are hundreds of thousands of weavers. More than any of these other trades, the biggest sort of industrial workforce in England at the beginning of the industrial revolution. So huge, huge number of jobs stand to be automated. And when people start to get angry about this, there aren't even that many power looms in operation.
它就能使织布以及最初生产商品的过程自动化。这是一件大事。有数十万织工。比其他任何行业都多，在工业革命初期，这是英国最大的产业工人队伍。所以，有数量极其庞大的工作岗位面临着被自动化的可能。而当人们开始对此感到愤怒时，实际投入运营的权力织机甚至没有那么多。
It's the idea. It's the fact that they're there, that entrepreneurs are beginning to use them, promising to use them. It's the long shadow that these things cast that really irks people. So you describe these technological innovations that led to increasing automation,
这是一种观念。是它们存在的事实，是企业家们开始使用它们、承诺使用它们这一事实。这些东西投下的长长的阴影真正惹恼了人们。所以你描述了导致自动化不断增加的技术创新，
but there was also the rise of just the factory as a space where production happens, right? So can you tell us a little bit more about that? So the factory was still kind of a novel concept at the time that you could organize, labor more efficiently if you gathered it all under one roof, under one overseer, and just start lining the place with machines. And this had not been done before, the 1700s in a meaningful way.
但同时兴起的还有工厂，也就是生产发生的空间，对吧？所以你能给我们多讲讲那个吗？因此，在当时工厂仍然是一个新颖的概念，如果你把劳动力集中在一个屋檐下一个监工手下，并开始在里面排满机器，你就能更有效地组织劳动力。在 1700 年代之前，这还没有以一种有意义的方式被做过。
So when it started happening, it immediately caused alarm bells to ring among cloth workers everywhere who saw pretty viscerally, what their lives were going to look like in the future if this mode of work took over their industry. I mean, it sounds like the factory itself is almost as important as any one of these new machines, like when it comes to changing the dynamics of work at the time. 100%. Yeah.
因此，当这种情况开始发生时，它立刻在各地的织工中敲响了警钟，他们非常直观地看到了如果这种工作模式接管他们的行业，他们的未来生活将会是什么样子。我的意思是，听起来工厂本身几乎和这些新机器中的任何一台一样重要，比如在改变当时的劳动动态方面。百分之百。是的。
In fact, the the Luddites and the people who would become Luddites had a saying, and that was what they hated most of all was to, quote, unquote, stand at their command. They hated this idea of becoming subservient to anyone, to an overseer, to a factory boss. When they'd lived their whole lives with autonomy, you know, working hard, but with flexibility and with dignity, if they had to stand at the command of somebody else, all that was out the window. It's the difference between working at home with your family, with your friends,
事实上，卢德分子以及将成为卢德分子的人有一句名言，那就是他们最痛恨的就是“听从命令”（stand at their command）。他们讨厌这种受制于任何人的想法，受制于监工，受制于工厂老板。当他们一生都拥有自主权时（你知道，努力工作，但有灵活性和尊严），如果他们必须听从别人的命令，所有这一切就都化为乌有了。这就像是在家里与家人、朋友一起工作，
taking breaks to walk in the garden, and sitting in a six-story building with worrying machinery and cloth fiber choking your lungs, and somebody telling you when you can and cannot stand up to take a break. One of the things I was really surprised by in your book is the role of that automation plate in creating child labor. Could you talk about that and why one led to the other? Yeah, so you don't need as much skill to run these new machines and so one thing you could do is you could hire children, women, hard-up
抽空去花园散步，与坐在一个六层楼的建筑里、面对着轰鸣的机器、肺部被织物纤维呛得喘不过气来、还有人对你指手画脚规定你什么时候可以、什么时候不能站起来休息之间的区别。在你的书中，让我感到非常惊讶的一件事是自动化在制造童工方面所起的作用。你能谈谈那个以及为什么一个会导致另一个吗？是的，所以运行这些新机器不需要那么高的技能，所以你能做的一件事就是你可以雇佣儿童、妇女、处境艰难的织工，
weavers who used to be more gainfully employed. And in these conditions that are sort of out of the public eye, they're these great big buildings, and they were purposefully built outside of major towns and cities because they knew people would both protest the jobs that they were taking. And soon enough, they knew that they both protest the jobs that they were taking, and soon enough, they knew that they would protest the conditions inside. And it's truly dangerous, brutal work. The limbs are lost frequently, children are pulled into the machines, disease would spread through the dormitories, and so many children died,
而他们过去曾有更好的就业机会。在这些远离公众视线的条件下，这些巨大的建筑物被刻意建造在主要城镇和城市之外，因为他们知道人们既会抗议他们夺走的工作。不久之后，他们知道人们既会抗议他们夺走的工作，不久之后，他们知道人们也会抗议内部的条件。这确实是危险、残酷的工作。肢体经常丢失，儿童被卷入机器，疾病在宿舍里蔓延，太多的儿童死亡，
that they had to ship them out of town and distribute them to different, on marked gravesites, so because they were afraid they would attract too much attention if they started filling in these mass graves right next to it. Truly awful, truly awful disturbing stuff. And that is one thing that cloth workers, the middle class, everywhere is seeing,
以至于他们不得不把他们运出城，分配到不同的、没有标记的墓地，因为他们担心如果他们开始在旁边填满这些万人坑，会引起太多的注意。确实很糟糕，确实很糟糕，令人不安的东西。这也是织工、中产阶级、到处的人们都能看到的一件事，
and they're saying, this is what the factory does. This is what automated machinery is leading us to. It's doing this to the most vulnerable of us, but we're all vulnerable here. So we see this rising discontent about automation. So from there, how did the Luddite movement begin? And when does it start to coalesce? So at the end of the 1700s, in response to the French Revolution, a lot of the British working class start to build a class consciousness and start to sort of agitate for reform and better conditions. The crown response in quite an authoritarian manner and one important thing they do
他们在说，这就是工厂所做的。这就是自动化机器把我们引向的方向。它对我们中最脆弱的人做出了这种事，但我们在这里都是脆弱的。所以我们看到了对自动化的不满情绪不断高涨。那么从那里开始，卢德运动是如何开始的？它是什么时候开始凝聚成形的？所以在 1700 年代末，为了回应法国大革命，许多英国工人阶级开始建立阶级意识，并开始为改革和更好的条件进行某种形式的鼓动。王室以相当专制的方式做出回应，他们做的一件重要事情
is they ban the act of combining or organizing or forming a union as we would understand it today. So that option is off the table. Workers cannot agitate collectively for change. That is illegal. They can be brought in and arrested if they do that. So as we enter the first decade of the 1800s and we start to see those big factories spring up, buying machinery, The workers don't have
是他们禁止了我们今天所理解的结合、组织或组建工会的行为。所以这个选项被排除了。工人不能联合起来争取改变。这是非法的。如果他们这样做，他们可能会被带走并逮捕。因此，当我们进入 1800 年代的第一十年，我们开始看到那些大工厂涌现，购买机器，工人们没有
that option of coming together and saying, hey, how are we going to deal with this? They try to anyways. So they form this nebulous trade organization. They go to parliament. They say, hey, these entrepreneurs are wrecking our trade. They are ignoring laws that are on the books. Can we deal with this? Can we deal this in a democratic way so that we all benefit a little bit from this new immense economic boom that's happening and so it doesn't just get concentrated
那种聚在一起说“嘿，我们该如何应对这个”的选择。他们无论如何都要尝试。于是他们组成了这个模糊的贸易组织。他们去议会。他们说，嘿，这些企业家正在破坏我们的行业。他们无视现有的法律。我们能解决这个问题吗？我们能用民主的方式解决这个问题，以便我们所有人都能从正在发生的这场巨大的经济繁荣中受益一点，而不至于让它只集中
at all at the top and we're just off their whims and they get denied. And finally, the British parliament at the time just says we've had enough of this. They wipe all those regulations off the books. So now they don't even have nominal regulations or laws to appeal to. You know, they go to their employers. They say, hey, let's work out some deals. Let's find a way that we can sort of introduce this technology more gradually. So it's not so sudden they get rebuffed there too.
在顶层，而我们只能听凭他们的异想天开，结果他们被拒绝了。最后，当时的英国议会只是说我们受够了这一切。他们将所有这些法规从法案中抹去。所以现在他们甚至没有名义上的规章或法律可以求助。你知道，他们去找他们的雇主。他们说，嘿，让我们达成一些协议吧。让我们找到一种方法，可以更循序渐进地引入这项技术。这样就不会那么突然，他们在那里也被断然拒绝了。
So it sounds like workers are trying to stay ahead of this trend towards automation. Like they're trying to push back, but they're just not having much success. Yeah, and finally, at the end of the decade, around 1809 out of 1810, we have this sort of crisis point. When the entrepreneur class recognizes that they have an advantage and they can sweep in and they begin introducing this automated machinery, and that is the final spark that lights this big flame. So let's talk about the name Luddite. It comes from this character named Ned Ludd. Who is he?
所以听起来工人们正试图在自动化这一趋势面前保持领先。就像他们试图反击，但只是没有取得太大成功。是的，最后，在这十年结束时，大约在 1809 年到 1810 年，我们迎来了这样一个危机点。当企业家阶层认识到他们拥有优势并且他们可以横扫千军并开始引入这种自动化机器时，这就是点燃这熊熊烈火的最终火花。所以让我们来谈谈“卢德”这个名字。它来自一个叫内德·卢德（Ned Ludd）的角色。他是谁？
Nedlod, who is he? Nedlod was a mythic and probably apocryphal figure. It's unclear where the name sort of came from first, although there's been a lot of speculation, if you say Nedlod, Robin Hood, Nedlod Robin Hood, it's kind of in the same vein and Nedlod originates in Nottingham, right next to Sherwood Forest, so there's the spirit of rebellion.
内德·卢德，他是谁？内德·卢德是一个神话般的、很可能是虚构的人物。目前还不清楚这个名字最初是如何来的，尽管有很多猜测，如果你说内德·卢德、罗宾汉，内德·卢德、罗宾汉，它们有点属于同一种调调，而且内德·卢德起源于诺丁汉，紧邻舍伍德森林，所以这里有着叛逆的精神。
But the first time that Ned Ludd appears is in a newspaper article that sort of details this backstory of an apprentice named Ned Ludd, who was a boy, forced to work on a machine, he didn't want to do his work because he's a boy. But the magistrate demands that he be whipped because he's not being productive enough, so the factory owner who's overseeing him whips him. Ned Ludd revolts, smashes the machine with a hammer, and flees into the forest. This is the legend of Ned Ludd, and it's either created or adopted by the cloth workers who, in 1811, finally decide that they've had enough and they organized a rebellion against the factory owners. So this marks the beginning of the Luddah movement
但内德·卢德第一次出现是在一篇报纸文章中，该文章详细描述了一个名叫内德·卢德的学徒的背景故事，他是一个男孩，被迫在一台机器上工作，因为他是个男孩，所以他不想干活。但治安官要求鞭打他，因为他的生产力不够，所以监督他的工厂老板鞭打了。内德·卢德反抗了，用锤子砸碎了机器，逃进了森林。这就是内德·卢德的传奇，它由纺织工人们创造或采纳，在 1811 年，他们终于决定受够了，并组织了一场反对工厂老板的叛乱。这标志着卢德运动的开始，
and their hallmark becomes that they destroy machines in the same way that mythical Ned Ludd did. Exactly. Their campaign is very organized, very pointed, very specific. First, what these followers of Ludd would do This very organized, very pointed, very specific. First, what these followers of LUD would do is they would send a letter, a threatening letter to a local entrepreneur or factory owner, and they would say, if you don't take down
他们的标志是他们像神话中的内德·卢德那样摧毁机器。完全正确。他们的运动非常组织化、非常尖锐、非常具体。首先，卢德的这些追随者会这样做：非常组织化、非常尖锐、非常具体。首先，LUD的这些追随者会这样做：他们会发出一封信，一封威胁信给当地的企业家或工厂老板，他们会说，如果你不拆除
these machines that you are using in this way, you're going to get a visit from Ned LUD's Army. you're going to get a visit from Nedlod's army. And it would be signed by Nedlod or General Lod or King Lod. And sure enough, if the entrepreneur didn't take down the machines, they would be targeted by a nighttime raid. They would either slip in through the windows and smash the machines that were doing the automation. And it's important to point, they would only smash those machines. There were a number of machines that had been used for a long time. Those machines would not be broken, hand limbs, not not broken. They would smash the wide frames. They would smash the
你以这种方式使用的这些机器，你将得到内德·LUD军队的拜访。你将得到内德·洛德军队的拜访。这封信将由内德·洛德、洛德将军或洛德国王签署。果不其然，如果企业家没有拆除机器，他们就会成为夜间突袭的目标。他们要么从窗户溜进去，砸碎那些负责自动化的机器。需要指出的是，他们只会砸碎这些机器。有许多机器已经使用了很长时间。那些机器不会被打破，手工织机，不会被打破。他们会砸碎阔幅织机（wide frames）。他们会砸碎
gig mills and the shearing frames, not those that had been used for hundreds of years. And then they would file out under the darkness of night. They were famous for brandishing the great blacksmiths hammer, and they would call it ENOC. The hammers themselves were made by James and ENOC tailor, who were blacksmiths that were also building automating machinery, so they had a saying, and that saying would go ENOC, made them, ENOC shall break them, and it was this great giant hammer. made them, you know, I shall break them. And it was this great giant hammer. So this first let it raid happens in Nottingham in 1811.
起毛机（gig mills）和剪毛机（shearing frames），而不是那些已经使用了数百年的机器。然后他们会在夜色笼罩下撤出。他们以挥舞巨大的铁匠锤而闻名，他们称之为伊诺克（ENOC）。锤子本身是由詹姆斯和伊诺克·泰勒制造的，他们是铁匠，同时也制造自动化机械，所以他们有一句名言，那句名言是：伊诺克制造了它们，伊诺克必将摧毁它们，这是一个巨大的大锤。制造了它们，你知道的，我必将摧毁它们。这是一个巨大的大锤。所以第一次卢德突袭发生在 1811 年的诺丁汉。
How does the movement spread from there? Yeah, I think one of the most interesting things about the let it movement is that it is a truly decentralized movement. It's an early sort of innovation really in this mode of sort of cell-based organizing. There was a well organized sortized sort of network of lightites in and around Nottingham. That came first.
运动是如何从那里传播开来的？是的，我认为关于卢德运动最有趣的事情之一是它是一场真正去中心化的运动。这是这种基于细胞（cell-based）的组织模式中的早期创新。在诺丁汉及其周边地区，有一个组织良好的卢德分子网络。这是最先出现的。
And they met with fairly astonishing success. So they would sneak into the factories, break the machines, and people cheered. Once they saw that public reaction was so good, they would do it again, and they got increasingly brazen. Soon there were raids in broad daylight as the crowds of the city would come out and cheer. So it's clear pretty early on that there's a lot of popular sentiment in favor of letism. And so you see
他们取得了相当惊人的成功。所以他们会潜入工厂，砸碎机器，人们欢呼雀跃。一旦他们看到公众反应如此之好，他们就会再次这样做，并且变得越来越放肆。不久之后，随着城市的民众走出来欢呼，光天化日之下的突袭也发生了。因此，很早就很明显，有大量的民意支持卢德主义。所以你会看到
let it cells start to crop up in various places, even where it's not clear that they were in touch. crop up in various places, even where it's not clear that they were in touch. In the beginning, it really was truly a decentralized movement, something like Occupy Wall Street or Black Lives Matter. It might be an analogous to that today. So who are some of the most important Luddite leaders who emerged during this time, but what drove them to the movement? So the interesting thing about Luddites is that they left very little trace. What we know about Luddites is largely through the letters they sent,
卢德分子的据点开始在各地涌现，甚至在不清楚他们是否有联系的地方也是如此。开始在各地涌现，甚至在不清楚他们是否有联系的地方也是如此。在开始的时候，它确实是一个真正去中心化的运动，有点像“占领华尔街”或“黑人的命也是命”。今天它可能与此类似。那么，在这期间涌现出的最重要的卢德领袖有哪些，是什么驱使他们加入这场运动的呢？关于卢德分子，有趣的是他们几乎没有留下什么痕迹。我们对卢德分子的了解很大程度上是通过他们发出的信件、
the complaints and descriptions passed down through the magistrates that fought them, the newspaper writers of the day, and you know through what was passed down through oral tradition. We do know a handful of the Leidite leadership, And the most famous is George Meller. George Meller had recently finished his apprenticeship as a cloth finisher or a cropper at the time that the entrepreneurs were starting to use automated machinery. So you can kind of imagine a young man going, ah, I finished my apprenticeship.
与他们战斗的治安官留下的投诉和描述、当代的报纸撰稿人，以及（你知道的）通过口头传统流传下来的内容。我们确实知道少数卢德分子的领导层，而其中最著名的是乔治·梅勒（George Meller）。在企业家开始使用自动化机器时，乔治·梅勒刚刚完成了作为布匹精整工或修剪工的学徒期。所以你可以想象一个年轻人说：“啊，我完成了学徒期。
Now I can sort of embark on the world and then seeing a factory spring up outside town and say, actually, we're gonna do that work for you and you're not gonna get paid anything anymore. So he is particularly incensed by all of this. So he agitates for this organized rebellion after Nottingham. So Nottingham comes first.
现在我可以开始闯荡世界了，”然后看到镇外冒出了一家工厂，说：“事实上，我们要为你做这项工作，你再也拿不到任何薪水了。”所以他对这一切感到格外愤怒。因此，在诺丁汉事件之后，他为这场有组织的叛乱进行了煽动。所以诺丁汉是第一步。
It's an inspiration to cloth workers everywhere. And George Meller is reading these accounts in the newspaper and saying we need to do this here. And so what was the government's reaction to the one I said they're gaining this popularity. They're becoming heroes and people are cheering them on even in broad daylight. What happens in terms of parliament? So the government is not pleased. Their response is swift and it is increasingly punitive, increasingly brutal. First, they just send troops. After there's an outbreak in Nottingham, the first Luddite uprising, they just send troops to occupy any of the villages or towns where these disturbances are going on. And the funny thing is, is that it doesn't matter.
这对各地的纺织工人都是一种鼓舞。乔治·梅勒正在阅读报纸上的这些报道，并说我们需要在这里这样做。那么，当他们获得这种人气时，政府对卢德分子的反应是什么？他们正在成为英雄，人们甚至在光天化日之下为他们欢呼。议会方面发生了什么？所以政府很不高兴。他们的反应是迅速的，而且越来越具有惩罚性，越来越残酷。首先，他们只是派军队。在诺丁汉爆发冲突、发生第一次卢德起居义后，他们只是派军队去占领任何发生这些骚乱的村庄或城镇。有趣的是，这根本没用。
The Luddites continue their campaigns and they slip right past. These troops, nobody is informing on the Luddites. The state puts huge rewards out there if anyone will come forward and inform on them, and nobody does. And when that doesn't work, they take the final step. And that is making it a crime punishable by death
卢德分子继续他们的行动，并且直接溜了过去。这些军队，没有人去告发卢德分子。如果有人站出来告发他们，国家会悬赏巨额奖金，但没有人这样做。当这不管用时，他们采取了最后一步。那就是把
to break a machine. So it gets the point or breaking a loom could have you put to death. So things are really escalating between the Luddites and the government. When does it all come to a hat? So the Luddites had been rising up for months and they had become very good at striking small to medium-sized operations
破坏机器的行为定为可判处死刑的罪行。所以事情发展到破坏织机可能会被处以死刑的地步。因此，卢德分子和政府之间的局势确实在升级。这一切什么时候达到了顶峰？所以卢德分子已经起义了好几个月，他们已经变得非常擅长打击中小型企业
and factories. There was a period where there were machine raids almost every day and hundreds and then thousands of machines were smashed, just a huge sums in that day of damage being done to the industrial state. But they felt, and specifically George Meller felt that it was time to strike a bigger blow. So this is probably the most famous battle in Luddite lore, but he gathers scores of men, there's over a hundred, and they attack what is then one of the biggest factories in the West Riding. A stone giant monolithic building and kind of unbeknownst to them, it has been built up like a fortress inside.
和工厂。有一段时间，几乎每天都有机器突袭，成百上千甚至数千台机器被砸碎，工业国家遭受了当时看来是巨额的损失。但他们觉得，尤其是乔治·梅勒觉得是时候给以更沉重的打击了。所以这可能是卢德传说中最著名的战役，他集结了数十人，有一百多人，他们袭击了当时西赖丁（West Riding）最大的工厂之一。那是一座由石头建造的庞大整体式建筑，而且在他们不知情的情况下，它在内部被建造得像堡垒一样。
It turns into this huge melee where the luttites are taking turns smashing this hammer and trying to shoot through the windows to try to gain entry so they can break the machines. But there are soldiers and mercenaries inside all shooting back at them. In the end, it's believed for, but two for sure, luddites are shot and killed and they have to retreat. The attack at Ruffold's Mill was really the luddites' first major defeat,
这演变成了一场巨大的混战，卢德分子轮流挥舞这把锤子，试图透过窗户射击以试图进入，这样他们就可以砸碎机器。但里面有士兵和雇佣兵，他们都在向他们开枪还击。最后，据信有四人，至少两人，卢德分子被枪杀，他们不得不撤退。鲁福尔德磨坊（Ruffold's Mill）的袭击确实是卢德分子遭遇的第一次重大失败，
and it was a huge turning point. It showed the factory owners that the Luddites could be turned back by force, that they could be crushed in this way, and that maybe the answer wasn't, you know, bounties or trying to ratchet up the penal code, but to simply encourage factory owners to defend their businesses with guns if necessary. So could you tell us how the Luddite movement eventually ended? Like, what led to their defeat?
这是一个巨大的转折点。它向工厂老板表明，卢德分子是可以被武力击退的，他们可以用这种方式被粉碎，也许答案不是（你知道的）悬赏或者试图收紧刑法，而是简单地鼓励工厂老板在必要时用枪支保卫他们的企业。所以你能告诉我们卢德运动最终是如何结束的吗？比如，是什么导致了他们的失败？
So after the defeat at Raffles, George Meller kind of goes up the deep end, one of his close friends, who he had personally convinced to become a Luddite John Booth, was among the dead, and he becomes pretty deeply unwell and he quickly resolves. He needs to take more direct action. So he enlists a few of his colleagues and they set out to attack the other major factory owner in town, a man named Horsefall, and they ambush him on his ride home and assassinate him in cold blood. So it becomes clear both by the body count and sort of by the way the winds are blowing that the luttites are losing. And after George and the other croppers assassinate horsefall, they also begin to lose public sentiment.
所以在拉夫尔斯（Raffles）战败后，乔治·梅勒有点走向了极端，他的一位挚友约翰·布斯（John Booth）——他曾亲自说服其成为卢德分子——在死者之列，他的情况变得相当糟糕，他迅速下定决心。他需要采取更直接的行动。于是他招募了几位同事，出发去袭击镇上的另一位主要工厂老板，一个名叫霍斯福尔（Horsefall）的人，他们在霍斯福尔骑马回家的路上伏击了他，并冷血地暗杀了他。因此，无论是通过死亡人数还是通过风向，都很明显卢德分子正在失败。在乔治和其他修剪工暗杀霍斯福尔之后，他们也开始失去公众的支持。
So all of this leads this most sort of explosive outburst of lethism to Peter out. Really the core let it uprising that we think about when we think about let it happen from 1811 to 1813 and it dies out by the end of the decade. And ultimately George Miller, the let it leader and his friends, were put to death for their role in the assassination, right? Yeah, yeah, it was a big dramatic trial. courtroom was packed. It was written about in the papers and You know, they never admitted to the assassination, but they were convicted pretty quickly and they were hung outside York Castle and then
所以所有这一切导致了这场最具爆发性的卢德主义爆发逐渐平息。实际上，当我们想到卢德发生时想到的核心卢德起义发生在 1811 年到 1813 年，并在十年结束前消亡了。最终，卢德领袖乔治·梅勒和他的朋友们因为他们在暗杀中所扮演的角色而被处决，对吧？是的，是的，那是一场轰动的大审判。法庭挤满了人。报纸上对此进行了报道，
just Days later there was a trial for all of those who had been participating in the movement otherwise, just for machine breaking, not for assassinating. First fall, and they were all put to death as well. It was a public affair. It was meant to send a signal to workers everywhere, because again, Luddites had become quite popular. Their movement was joined, not just by cloth workers, but by shoemakers, by coal workers, by people of every stripe.
而且（你知道的）他们从未承认暗杀，但他们很快被判有罪，并在约克城堡外被绞死，然后
Working people understood the structures that were taking shape, and that this mode of factory work, especially, and having to tend to the machines owned by somebody else was so onerous that it was worth fighting to preserve their way of life, to preserve their freedom, basically. So how did the defeat of the Luddites represent like a new template for labor relations and also just, you know, the way we make and build things going for it? and also just, you know, the way we make and build things going forward. The defeat of the Luddites meant that the factory owners won, and that this mode of production gets replicated everywhere. We get the industrial revolution, and it's largely a factory revolution. So when the Luddites lost, on the one hand,
就在几天后，对所有其他参与该运动的人进行了审判，仅仅是因为破坏机器，而不是因为暗杀霍斯福尔，他们也都被处决了。这是一场公开的事件。它旨在向各地的工人发出信号，因为再次说明，卢德分子已经变得非常受欢迎。他们的运动不仅有纺织工人加入，还有鞋匠、煤矿工人以及各行各业的人加入。劳动人民理解正在成型的结构，而且这种工厂工作模式（特别是必须照看由别人拥有的机器）是如此繁重，以至于为了保护他们的生活方式、基本上是为了保护他们的自由，与之一战是值得的。那么卢德分子的失败如何代表了一种劳动关系的新模板，以及（你知道的）我们制造和建造事物的前进方式？以及（你知道的）我们制造和建造事物的前进方式。卢德分子的失败意味着工厂老板赢了，这种生产模式在各地得到了复制。我们迎来了工业革命，它在很大程度上是一场工厂革命。所以当卢德分子失败时，一方面，
this particular mode of work became ascendant. And on the other hand, it became taboo to question how technology was used and how it was used in your workplace, how it was used against you, if it was going to be used against you. Technology became synonymous with progress, and to say otherwise, could get you labeled backwards thinking or just sort of ignorant. And this was also very intentional. And we see that when in the prosecutor is prosecuting George Meller and the Luddites, he's using these terms.
这种特定的工作模式占据了主导地位。另一方面，质疑技术如何被使用以及它如何在你的工作场所被使用、它如何被用来对付你（如果它要被用来对付你）成了一种禁忌。技术成了进步的同义词，而说不则会让你被贴上思想落后或无知的标签。这也是非常刻意的。我们看到当检察官起诉乔治·梅勒和卢德分子时，他正在使用这些词。
He's decrying that men like George Meller have led other men under this delusion that machinery is not progress. So we see this equation early on begin to be formulated by those who it stands to benefit. Coming up after the break, we'll talk more with Brian Merchant about the ways that the Luddite movement still echoes today and whether we might see another lead-eye uprising. So I'm back with Brian Merchant, and Brian, I have to say, I'm kind of flambragasted by how thoroughly the lead-ites were defeated.
他在谴责乔治·梅勒这样的人引导其他人陷入这种错觉，即机械化不是进步。所以我们看到这种等式很早就开始由那些将从中受益的人构建出来。中场休息后，我们将与布赖恩·莫昌特更多地探讨卢德运动在今天仍然产生的回响，以及我们是否会看到另一场卢德起义。所以我又和布赖恩·莫昌特在一起了，布赖恩，我必须说，我对卢德分子被彻底击败的程度感到震惊。
Like not only was the movement defeated in its time, but the word itself lead-eye was taken over by, you know, capillus and industrialists to mean anti-progress and anti-technology and kind of a blind, ignorant way. Like that level of defeat, like even at the level of a language is kind of hard to fathom. Yeah, it really is.
不仅这场运动在其时代被击败，而且“卢德”这个词本身也被（你知道的）资本家和实业家接管，变成以一种盲目、无知的方式反对进步和反对技术的意思。这种程度的失败，甚至在语言层面上也是很难理解的。是的，确实如此。
There's a scholar, theater, Rosac, who once said about the Luddites, and I love this, he said, if the Luddites didn't exist, then the tech industry would have to invent them. I think it's been very intentional on some level by the people who stand to benefit most from a lot of these technologies
有一位学者西奥·罗萨克（Theodore Roszak）曾经关于卢德分子说过这样的话，我非常喜欢，他说，如果卢德分子不存在，那么科技行业就必须发明他们。我认为，在某种程度上，从那些从许多这类技术中获益最多的人那里来看，这是非常刻意的，
that we would do very well to question to have us not question them. It serves that bottom line. We're not asking questions about how Amazon gets us our products so cheaply and so quickly, and that to say, maybe it's not worth the cost if we understand what's going on behind the scenes, if that is backwards looking, then Amazon wins.
我们最好不要去质疑它们。这符合底线。我们没有提出关于亚马逊如何如此便宜、如此迅速地将产品送到我们手中的问题，如果说，如果我们了解幕后发生的事情，也许它不值得付出代价，如果这被认为是思想落后，那么亚马逊就赢了。
If we say maybe there should be safeguards or rules about how AI is used or situations where it should not be used at all in the workplace, if saying things like that makes us look sort of foolish, that serves companies like OpenAI that stand to make enormous profits from selling these tools to other enterprises. So it does make a certain level of sense that the Luddite term has been captured so thoroughly by, I guess you could say, its opponents. Do you think we might see a new kind of Luddite uprising in reaction to developments and automation today?
如果我们说，也许应该对人工智能的使用方式制定保障措施或规则，或者在工作场所根本不应该使用它的情况，如果说这样的话让我们看起来有点愚蠢，这有利于像 OpenAI 这样从向其他企业出售这些工具中获得巨大利润的公司。所以，从某种水平上讲，“卢德”这个词被（我想你可以这么说）它的反对者如此彻底地夺取，是有一定道理的。你认为我们可能会看到一种新型的卢德起义来应对今天的自动化发展吗？
I do think we'll see some new threads of letism being woven, so to speak. I think we already are. So again, the Luddites did not have the tools that we have available to us. We do have the ability to organize our workplaces and to confront AI or automation if it's being used in ways that can cause us harms. And we are finally seeing that. And I think that is ledism. And that is something that we haven't seen for decades now.
我确实认为我们会看到卢德主义的一些新线索被编织进去，可以说是这样的。我想我们已经在这样做了。所以再次说明，卢德分子没有我们手头可用的工具。我们确实有能力组织我们的工作场所，并在人工智能或自动化被用于可能对我们造成伤害的方式时与之对抗。我们终于看到了这一点。我认为这就是卢德主义。这是我们几十年来一直没有看到的东西。
And I'm talking about the actors and the screenwriters strike, which is predicated in large part over grievances about AI and sort of the giggification of their work. It's very much explicit. Both the screenwriters and the writers are drawing a red line in the way that we might imagine the Luddites drawing that line and saying, no, you cannot use chat GPT or an AI service to create an original script because we know that what you want to do is have the AI turn out an original script and then to pay us less money to edit it.
我说的是演员和编剧罢工，这在很大程度上是基于对人工智能的不满以及他们工作的零工化（giggification）。这非常明确。编剧和作家都在画一条红线，就像我们想象卢德分子画的那条红线一样，他们说，不，你不能使用 ChatGPT 或人工智能服务来创建原创剧本，因为我们知道你想做的是让人工智能炮制出一个原创剧本，然后付给我们更少的钱来修改它。
And that's exactly what was happening 200 years ago. You know, they couldn't get rid of the person altogether, but they could make sort of a shoddy substitute. And it's that saying no that just resonates so deeply with what Buddhism is all about. A lot of what the Luddites were fighting against is so timeless because the way that we develop technology and the way it's imposed on our economy is so much the same. To the extent that if you look back 200 years and you look at some of the solutions Luddites were proposing, they were proposing things that today look an awful lot like a robot tax
这正是 200 年前发生的事情。你知道，他们无法完全摆脱这个人，但他们可以做出一个劣质的替代品。正是这种说“不”的精神，与卢德主义的本质产生如此深层的共鸣。卢德分子所反对的很多东西都是永恒的，因为我们开发技术的方式以及它强加给我们的经济的方式是如此相似。以至于如果你回顾 200 年前，看看卢德分子提出的一些解决方案，他们提出的东西在今天看起来非常像机器人税，
that would be proposed by someone like Andrew Yang or Michael Bloomberg, where if you're using automated machinery, then some portion of that cloth that you would not otherwise be able to produce, you should tax that and then use that to fund worker programs. This is something that they suggested 200 years ago. And they saw the way that tech titans and entrepreneurs were using the idea of technology to get around regulations in much the same way that 200 years later, Uber and Lyft and the gig economy companies would be using to say, oh, we're a technology company.
这会由像安德鲁·杨（Andrew Yang）或迈克尔·布隆伯格（Michael Bloomberg）这样的人提出，如果你在使用自动化机器，那么你本来无法生产的那部分布料的一部分，你应该对其实施税收，然后用它来资助工人项目。这是他们在 200 年前建议的事情。他们看到科技巨头和企业家如何利用技术的概念来绕过法规，就像 200 年后，Uber、Lyft 和零工经济公司所做的那样，他们说，哦，我们是一家科技公司。
We don't have to play by the municipal tax decode rules or anything like that. So this playbook has remained the same for for for so long and it's going to be the same Unless we really sort of take major strides to to address it Would you like to see people like use the word luddite today in the proper way? Like is this like a mission? It is a mission. I have become a very pro-luddite I will fight this battle any day of the week. I think the time is right to reclaim the term, and I think we all benefit greatly if we succeed.
我们不必遵守城市税收法典规则或类似的东西。所以这个剧本已经存在了这么久，而且它将保持不变，除非我们真正采取重大举措来解决它。你希望看到人们在今天以正确的方式使用“卢德分子”这个词吗？这就像是一个使命吗？这是一个使命。我已经成了一个坚定的亲卢德分子。我一周七天随时准备打这场仗。我认为现在是夺回这个词的时候了，而且我认为如果我们成功了，我们所有人都会受益匪浅。
99% of the visible was produced this week by Delaney Hall, sound mix by Dara Hirsch, original music by Swanrielle. Kathy too is our executive producer Kurt Colestad is the digital director. Press the team includes Martin Gonzales, Chris Barube, Jason Dillion, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Lashemadon, Jacob Maldonado Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me, Roman Mars. Brian Merchand's book will be available for purchase on September 26th. It's called Blood in the Machine, the origins of the rebellion against Big Tech. There is so much detail we couldn't get into, bloody detail, incredible characters, so much going on. If you want to learn more about
本周的 99% Invisible 由德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）制作，达拉·希尔施（Dara Hirsch）负责声音混音，原创音乐由斯旺里尔（Swanrielle）创作。凯西·图（Kathy Tu）是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯塔德（Kurt Colestad）是数字总监。新闻团队包括马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzales）、克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Barube）、杰森·狄龙（Jason Dillion）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、薇薇安·李（Vivian Leigh）、拉舍马·顿（Lashemadon）、雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳（Jacob Maldonado Medina）、凯利·普赖姆（Kelly Prime）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。布赖恩·莫昌特的书将于 99 月 26 日发售。书名叫《机器里的血：反抗大科技叛乱的起源》。这里有太多我们无法深入探讨的细节，血腥的细节，不可思议的角色，太多的事情正在发生。如果你想了解更多关于
the Lennites, you definitely have to check it out. The 99% invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are a part of the Stitcher and Serious XM podcast family now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI work or on Instagram, Reddit, and TikTok too.
卢德分子的信息，你绝对必须去看看。99% Invisible 的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。我们现在是 Stitcher 和 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分，总部设在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城区潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。你可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与有关该节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我，账号是 Roman Mars，也可以@该节目，账号是 99PI work，或者在 Instagram、Reddit 和 TikTok 上也可以找到。
You can find links to others to share your shows I love as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在 99PI.org 上找到分享你喜爱的节目的链接以及 99PI 的每一集过往节目。你 这里还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。